vous devez impérativement faire ça pour
votre iPhone viennent protéger vos
oreilles vous allez dans son et
vibrations ensuite dans sécurité des
écouteurs et là vous venez activer
diminuer les sons forts ça viendra
diminuer les sons les plus forts au-delà
d'un certain niveau de décibels vous
choisissez 85 décibels 90 95 sans
décibels sans c'est très fort je vous
recommande ici 85 décibels ça correspond
au niveau d'un restaurant bruyant comme
ça s'il y a un son de plus de 85
décibels qui arrivent dans vos oreilles
votre casque le réduira et ça vous
protégera les oreilles est-ce que vous
connaissez cette astuce dites le moi
dans les commentaires et pour en savoir
toujours plus pensez à bien vous abonner